I am my name is Ethan Bogle I am a
senior at Stanford University and online
high school and my talk is titled
developing a culture of computational
thinking I am talking about a curriculum
or a computational thinking course pilot
that I had signed and I'm running this
year at my school
hey everyone my name is Ethan Bogle I am
a senior at Stanford University online
high school I'm here to talk today about
developing a culture of computational
thinking it's great seal'
so I'm going to be talking about a creek
ulam that I designed for a pilot course
about computational thinking at my
school and the purpose behind the
curriculum is basically to spread
computational thinking building interest
and excitement in my school community
develop a culture of computational
thinking as it were given an audience
who does not know about computational
thinking and especially if since there's
not necessarily another common interest
to leverage how do you catch somebody's
interest and and basically just I'm
going to be talking about the design
that I have for achieving that so
different amounts of opportunities for
students to spend however much time they
have available the presentations on
topics each week various other things
and I'll show a few examples and talk
about my experiences using the
curriculum so far so can my journey I
really liked computational thinking
Wolfram language I attended the 2018
wolfram summer camp and started a
computational thinking Club at my school
last year but then I kind of realized I
wanted to do a little bit more
computational thinking is something that
it's not just a hobby or interest it's
something that can be more widely
applicable and so I actually proposed a
course to my school administration and
to my surprise they actually said how
about you teach a pilot course and so I
was at the 2019 wolfram summer school
building the curriculum for that course
which I'm going to be talking about
today all this goal being to develop a
culture of computational thinking so
this is the pitch that I made for the
the course as an advertisement to
students
and volume is not transmitting
so this this pitch basically being the
advertisement so the main design piece
behind the main idea behind the design
is basically you're taking a group of
people who don't know what kind of
occasionally thinking is and you're
trying to convince them to learn about
computational thinking on their own time
because that's where we are right now
and the key thing is you're not doing
that through you're not assigning work
necessarily because you can't do that
yet but that otherwise we wouldn't need
something like this but instead it's
through getting their interests
so let's see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so very and you saw dr. Hoshi who's
actually our head of school
he officially it's his thing but I'm
basically running it so I so as I
starting to say so basically how do we
convince the students to spend their own
time and and the way we do that is we
present it something that they can apply
to their everything that they already
are doing so it's not this new hobby or
this new academic subject they have to
add it's something that helps them do
the things they're already doing and
honestly that's kind of why I fell in
love with the often language I'm a math
person I may I like that wolfin language
can do math but the reason I love Wolfen
language is because it can do everything
not just math so that's kind of my
philosophy if that's what we should be
doing that's how we spread it so goal in
other words being to develop
computational literacy so that students
can apply that to the things they're
already doing so basically sessions as I
designed them were there's two pieces
there's the topics presentations there's
work time and basically the topics
presentation is my chance to say hey
here's something you can do with the
Wolfram language and that's get
something they can then jump off of if
they are interested if they find that
interesting
and then the work time is the time for
them to pursue that or to do something
else so they can either be working
through kind of the technical aspects of
elementary obstruction to the Wolfram
language or they can do another
exploratory activity whatever they find
interesting for themselves and then I
also have an exit ticket that basically
allows me to keep track of what students
are up to and I hold weekly office hours
also kind of as an optional place for
students to out come ask for help work
on things that sort of stuff
so one of the key pieces here is the
path so you've got this computational
thinking lands that you want to bring
these students to so but these are very
busy students their high school or you
could apply this easily in a college
setting University students and they
have a lot of things going on and maybe
no matter how interested they are they
just don't have the time so there may be
a tourist they need to they may not be
able to come and do stuff except for
during the meeting well that's okay
we've got they can do that but maybe
they have more time and they want to do
more with the wealth and language then
they can learn more or at the other
extreme if they wanted to do a project
or they really got interested in wealth
and language I like a lot of us here
then they could and they had the time to
spend they could spend that time and do
a project and so basically it's having
different paths it based on how much
time they people can spend it basically
gives students permission to come as
they are because then a tourist does
isn't doesn't feel like oh I can't do
the what the other people in the class
are doing because I don't have enough
time I might as well not participate or
the expat might is able to say they
can't say all I'm Way ahead I'm more
interested in this than other people I
be I'd be too far ahead for it to be
useful for me to show up and that way
everybody feels they have permission to
come as where they are so just as far as
platform I designed it in Google Docs
are sorry Google classroom just because
it was free and easy to use so okay so
the topics the topics are kind of a
central piece here and again the
question is what could I use this for so
the three components are what is an
example of something computational
thinking welcome language can do
examples and and the key about the
examples is they have to
kind of there's a balance between
generality and specificity you have to
strike because they have to be general
enough that you can apply them to lots
of different things and they'll be
interesting to a lot a large set of the
students but they also have to be
specific enough that you that the
student can actually understand what's
going on with the code even if they
don't understand all of it at least
ideally they should be able to modify
the code without too much help to do
something useful that's not what it was
originally written to apply to so that's
kind of a key there and then the third
piece is so that the students can go
further if it's something that they find
interesting whether the further
resources where the further places for
them to go as far as like choosing what
to do a topic presentation about it's
kind of obvious considerations
what's the existing culture at your
school what would people find useful I
happen to come from a very humanities
oriented school and so there's a kind of
a strong demand for that but also what
is surprising cuz there's everybody
knows that Mathematica can do math and
science so what are the things that are
surprising and honestly that is the
humanity stuff it's the stuff like
mapping and text analysis and I mean
some of the machine learning stuff and
so personally I didn't actually write a
single STEM related session all of mine
are on the other stuff because that's
what's surprising that's what's not
obvious as far as and that's also the
audience that I'm trying to appeal to as
far as convincing some people that this
is important so okay so here's a few
examples of those sessions that I did so
obvious example would be Wolfram Alpha
one of our first sessions it's a great
entry point especially with Wolfram
Alpha a notebook Edition coming out soon
that this this type of exploration will
be even more powerful but I mean it
didn't have to do a whole lot for it
because I just did an 80 second video
that I found somewhere on the Wolfram
website and then I basically said
okay jump in and explore alright another
one notebook interface it's one of the
first sessions that we do but I also
built it almost entirely from an
existing presentation so this is a thing
that you don't have to do a long thing
and you don't have to be write a whole
lot necessarily yourself you're because
with it with the template all you really
need to do is find somebody else who's
already written a code you can find code
that's already out there somewhere or a
presentation that's already out there
somewhere and you just can then
repurpose that it's just not in the
format or in a obvious defined place
necessarily so you just put it you can
just find it and put it into your
presentation so it's that makes it a lot
easier especially if you're not
necessarily an expert you couldn't write
the code if you can at least understand
the code and find it that's good enough
and it allows you to talk about a lot of
different things so Maps is another one
that I did it is in a iwl but I wanted
to get to it sooner
since maps are kind of one of the
surprising aspects of open language it's
also very useful for a lot of different
things you can plot historic history
data you can do things about analyzing
English texts and basically it's a very
very diverse tool for studying
especially humanities types of things so
I wanted to get to it sooner okay so
here's getting into more of the actual
nitty gritty type analysis examples so
social network graphs
I took a Wolfram blog post about
analyzing Shakespeare's texts and I
changed the subject of that I just took
the code and I changed it from Othello
to Hamlet and because that's what my
school studies but I mean I was able to
do that very easily and so of course the
students there could take the code very
easily and adapt it to a different play
that they were studying especially a
Shakespeare play
so and we've got then this nice visual
which you can use either as a source for
further computation since it is a wolf
and language graph or you could just use
it as a nice visual you can see Hamlet's
at the centre Horacio his best friend is
kind of right next to him that's that
makes that all kind of makes sense okay
and here's another example so literary
style analysis so comparing two
different pieces of text I I have an
excerpt here from that session the first
part I cover fine textual answer it's
just kind of a nice big machine learning
function and then I also mentioned kind
of doing it a word search in a text like
that's a that's something that you
wouldn't necessarily think of doing
necessarily with the Wolfram language
but it is something that it is a
computational idea it's a it's
computational approach to looking at a
text and even making that connection is
kind of useful to make so and then I
talked about this getting into analyzing
so basically I start with my clear
statement of purpose which is to die
listicle II compare different speakers
in a play and of course you could adapt
this to any two texts but I'm looking at
the dialogue in a play so I got the text
of Hamlet using this code which is code
that I had already introduced before so
students
oh okay suppose I'm not going to be
running the code today so the least this
students already know either they know
what it does or they could do it on
their own or in this particular case
this is just getting the text and
cleaning it up in a way that you could
just do by hand actually so this is not
something that's too hard to do and then
I take let's pick three characters from
that play and so and then I get their
dialogue so this example here it's you
can see how easily you could modify that
to do any other character from the play
any other character from another play
you might happen to have etc so
basically they can then look at any
characters they want anything and then
once they have that data they can do
whatever they want with analyzing the
comparison so you can make a word cloud
of the data gives you a nice overview of
the of a comparison you can look at okay
who speaks the most Hamlet kind of the
obvious result but Claudius maybe
surprisingly speaks a lot less than
Hamlet surprisingly less and a philia
and maybe given her role of speaks even
less so that maybe is not a surprising
but it's it's verifies what you might
think so okay who tends to speak the
longest on average well handle it
obviously is up there but surprisingly
Claudius maybe has more longer speech
speeches which is interesting because
you usually would think of Hamlet as the
one who's writing who has has all the
soliloquies so you can look at histogram
you can look at the distribution well
okay you start to see okay Hamlet does
have the longest one down here and has
some pretty long ones here but Claudius
also has a lot more long ones up here
and Hamlet has a lot of these really
short quips so that would explain why
that may be that result happened that
why we got that result so and now I've
kind of given a brief quick one off here
of analysis and now students can take
that and do whatever analysis they want
they have the they have the dialogue
they can do any sort of text they want
honor that and it's open-ended and if
they don't if they did not find that
gripping at all they can go back to
doing whatever it was they they found
interesting but if they found this
interesting then this is a whole new
avenue for them to explore and they've
already got something they can easily
adapt okay so to wrap up so far
turns out I couldn't hold people for
more than 30 minutes I didn't realize
that but that's actually kind of fine
that's exactly the sort of thing of I'm
giving them something and then letting
them choose what to do at their time so
we've had good attendance as far as in
the context of my school we haven't done
obviously there's no assignments we
haven't done any projects yet we're
starting to turn to that and so because
of that there hasn't necessarily been a
whole lot of activity in office hours
because of that but I think that'll
that'll probably change soon the
presentations have been going very
smoothly which is that's a part of the
design that's been working well and we
actually just had our mid semester
survey so here is a few excerpts from
the speed back that I got from the mid
semester survey and I'll let you read
that for a moment
so here here's another question that I
asked that people had the chance to
respond to
and here's the last question so what
have you learned as it were
so as you can see the feedback that I've
been getting has been very much in line
with what I was trying to go for and I
I'm very excited for how this is going
to continue into the future so as far as
action items if you're interested in
seeing some of the materials that I
built in Google classroom just talk to
me I can give you that link or send me a
message in path poll the slides and also
my computational essay about
computational essays and kind of that
role that that serves in in in in a
school setting and in academic setting
those are all passable if you want to
look at those and then I also have posts
on the Welcome community talking about
this stuff so if you look me up on the
wulfing community as far as like action
items so if you're a student start a
club or a class on computational
thinking what think about what role
computational thinking can play in your
curriculums so and then act on that
start using that in your in your classes
and then impress your instructors and
then the same goes what if for faculty
and staff so impress your students with
what the wealth and language can do look
and and find the wolfram student
ambassadors and the other wolfram
enthusiasts at your school and and and
see if you can find somebody to partner
what to create this to create a club or
a course and start showing people what
you can do with computational thinking
so I I think I've made a good first step
at this this goal of developing a
culture of computational thinking and I
think this experiment is working out
fairly well so far and it'll be exciting
to see where it goes thank you for
coming are there any questions
you
[Applause]